[Music]
chuck
yes i have an idea for an explainer
okay it's just i just want to riff
on plants and animals okay i don't know
if there's a lesson in here or
insights but i just have a lot of
thoughts i'm just going to sort of
spill them out right okay well here's my
first thought
both delicious
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so here here i just want to
just
share some points of view so
uh do you remember all of the
the concerns people had about
uh tuna being caught
by nets right
and the issue wasn't that tuna were
being caught by nets
it was that the nets were dolphins
dolphins right because dolphins aren't
delicious
and tuna is no that wasn't okay so
the argument was in the net the
the tuna can breathe but the dolphin
can't
right because a dolphin is an air
breather and it doesn't breathe in the
water
so you kill the dolphins if the net
doesn't come up quick
quickly enough yeah you drown them okay
and basically they drown
all right so which by the way
i'm just gonna say whether you believe
in a god or not
if i breathe air and i live in the water
maybe there's something wrong with that
design you had it coming to you
yeah you kind of were asking for it okay
you breathe air but you live in the
water and when you drown you kind of had
it coming
i was just saying all right well here's
something about the dolphin because it
breathes and
eats from two different orifices in its
body
it means it can't
choke while eating the way we can
how you like that well i got it there's
no dolphin that ever choked from eating
a pastrami sandwich i'm just saying
this is true now that that however is
not a design
flaw for us because i don't want to look
at somebody with a butthole in their
neck
so it's a it's a design failure for us
in a design feature for the dolphin they
know they're swimming in the water all
right here's my point
the fact that we're protecting the
dolphins but eating the tuna
i remember thinking to myself why
doesn't anybody care about the tuna
right it's it's also a big fish all
right it had a life
in the ocean and so i realized
that we have species bias
among us yeah i'm gonna go with i'm
we we have species bias we're saying i
don't want to admit what you're saying
is true
and we don't want to admit it well i
don't want to admit it but we don't
like to admit it yeah but it's there i
just want to reveal this in case people
hadn't
thought it through all right so we're
saying we value
the dolphin over the
we're not talking about vegetarians here
who would eat neither but for those who
would eat the
the tuna and specifically not eat the
dolphin
because it's a mammal so what you're
saying is
that in the tree of life which has
fungus and bacteria and plants and
animals you have taken this
slender branch in that tree of life
called mammals
which is a offshoot from vertebrates
okay so both dolphins and
and and tuna are vertebrates but
dolphins are spin-off of that called
mammals
and they lactate they give live birth
as do we so we are saying you are close
enough to us
that we value your life above
other life on this tree of life
and some people said no it's not that
they're mammals it's that they have big
brains their brain is
larger than us okay so now we're saying
now we're saying we value them because
they have big brains
okay all right whatever rules you want
to invoke i just want to make sure
people fully understand that
every living thing on earth
is as far away from an
evolutionary place
from the very first single celled life
as is all other life on earth okay
so you're saying oh the brain is
important for survival oak trees are
still alive today
and they don't have any brains okay
and they're doing just fine earthworms
are doing just fine
and they coexist with us four and a half
billion years after the earth has formed
so all i'm saying is that whatever
struggles
trials and tribulations we went through
as vertebrate mammals
okay whatever we went through
every single other living thing on this
earth
has also survived to this point
species that is or evolved to fit
this point so and so you want to value
judge it
this is a mammal this has a brain all
right but
have you stopped and thought about what
a tree
is a tree
is different it lives you but but it
can't stop me from chopping it down so
it doesn't have a say in this
okay i will chop down that oak tree and
build a boat and then take that
earthworm
and catch a tuna and eat it
chuck you violated
[Laughter]
chuck don't play all right but you know
what the oak tree will do
it won't budge when you careen
off the road in your car this is true
okay
the mass of that oak tree vastly exceeds
you
plus your automobile and so many people
have not
survived an encounter with a tree well
as a survivor i can tell you that you're
absolutely right and geico knows it
geico knows it and the tree is
delivering oxygen
to the air cyclically through the
seasons that we
breathe and one of the most famous poems
ever penned
was about trees brownings what's that i
thought it was joyce kilmer
oh is that joyce kilmer i i think that i
shall never see
a poem lovely as lovely as a tree so for
me i like
artists and in this case poets i don't
need them to commemorate
amazing facts and and famous events
i need them to remind me of what i've no
longer pay attention to
and for me that's why that poem rose up
that's a beautiful
thought yeah it just forces you to
reflect on it so
at night there's a problem so far with
your
suppositions and your premise no one has
ever
written a poem about a tuna
maybe i don't know
i'm sure there's a japanese person
somewhere that wrote a poem about a tuna
but it's sushi tuna
exactly
[Laughter]
ain't no bumble bee we're not talking
about no bumble bee
so here's my point so we go through this
tree of life
and cherry pick it for things we
like for whatever reasons we invoke at
the time
and we could be influential on others
and gather groups of people
to feel the same way about that so
you will not kill an animal to eat it
but you will slaughter all manner of
plant life
and eat it so you're okay with that
but not eating the animals you have
judged that your side of the tree of
life
is more important than this other side
of the tree of life
and there's another very important point
i want to make
even sticking with the animal side of
the tree of life
because we're animals and we're even
even so
we prefer the fuzzy cuddly ones
all right we prefer you know why is it
that the squirrel is cute
but the opossum is nasty
all right is it because the opossum
doesn't have hair on its tail yes and
it's not bushy
and it doesn't look at you it's ugly all
right so we are value
judging animals on their beauty for what
we want to protect and what we don't
they're things that we would most of us
would just assume not have
like lethal viruses like ticks
like mosquitoes like like bacteria you
know dysentery
these are life forms that we share the
earth with
you know where is the community of
people that's saying save the ticks
all right somehow we're all okay
exterminating them
killing them getting them out of there
but all because they carry disease
uh or uh not only ticks the who the
jumpers the um
fleas the fleas okay the fleas
all by all account carried the bubonic
plague if you
if the world never had another flea you
probably wouldn't miss it but that meant
you would be exterminating
a branch of the tree of life a species
in the tree of life
because it's not convenient for you and
so
i we are about to completely eradicate
the there's a worm what's it called the
guinea worm any worm which only affects
humans
all right we're about to completely
eradicate that we
basically eradicated smallpox right well
what about the smallpox microbes
all right how do they feel about this so
i'm just i'm just saying get a lawyer
just like everybody else
so i'm not i'm not landed anywhere i
just
think about all of life and all the
struggles that life had to go through
to get to where it is today in the tree
of life
four and a half billion years after life
began
and so when i when i eat lettuce or
cucumber i'm thinking
uh you know like as they say with the
native americans i'm
thankful to the plant any in the same
way i'm thankful to the pig or the cow
or the
you know whatever else these are things
that were alive
keep in mind we're kind of stuck killing
in order to survive as
primitive as that might be in the galaxy
it's that anything you can digest
was once alive be it plant or animal
so we live on a planet where all animals
kill other living things to survive
all animals every single one of them up
and down
when you're brutal man this earth is
brutal people talk about oh let's get in
harmony with nature nature's imbalance
nature was never imbalanced
you go in there this like dog eat dog or
plant eat
plant kill plant oh let me put shade on
you now i got the sunlight and you don't
all right and you wither and die and
some other plant and the animal eats you
and it is it is yeah it feels like it's
equilibrium
from season to season but you step back
year to year decade to decade century to
century
there's stuff shifting all the time
so i i just think of all life as sacred
and i don't having after having done so
i don't
value judge one life over another based
on his proximity
to us on the tree of life because it's
all here
and we're all sharing the same earth if
i were to design earth differently i'd
have everybody have to go through
photosynthesis
then you wouldn't have to kill anything
right just go out and sunbathe i got my
day's energy today
all right let's go running you know oh
god i have a beautiful tan
and i'm so full i'm so full of energy
that's right
that's right so aliens that might only
thrive on photosynthesis from their host
planet or its equivalent
will come here and wonder what the hell
is wrong with humans
wow man listen this is i don't mean to
get all deep on you here but i just
i mean this is really some deep
philosophical stuff man
i think about it all the time when i'm
preparing food
yeah yeah wow okay i don't want to be
speciesist how about this how about this
how about if i just cut the leaves off
of plants but i never take the plant
down i just prune the plant and i eat
the parts of the plant like like if i
were to harvest children but only eat
their fingers
what what no no here he would he would
be
you you harvest colonies of newts and
you bite off their legs and tails
right how about that that's a new diet
the newt diet
um yeah so i'm not i this was not a was
this an explainer video i don't know it
was more just me sharing
with you some of my thoughts i don't
know man
we're definitely gonna get some feedback
on this one man but i i think it's a
very
interesting premise to ponder because
it challenges our biases and causes us
to re assess our perspectives
because most of what we are assigning
value to
is done so based on what we deem
valuable
period right period yeah yeah the brain
that's
a spinal column you know mammal
features yeah it's just we've made a
judgment
and i don't i don't know
that i'm prepared to do that because i
respect all life
and until we have organizations that say
save the ticks
um i you know save the roaches
save the rats now i'm just gonna say
that back in the late 80s
uh when i used to do this we did have a
little save the roaches
like uh consortium but it was a
different kind of roach
okay okay
hey man you gonna throw that away no man
speaking of animals you needed the
alligator clip
to hold the roach there you go
i'm neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist keep looking
[Music]